today we're going to talk about how to
look younger now if you tell people what
to do without the why to do it a lot of
times they won't do it so today i'm
going to go into the why as well as what
to do this information is good for new
people as well as those people who have
been watching my channel for quite some
time so to look younger on the outside
you really have to be younger on the
inside now and when we're dealing with a
youthful look
we're dealing with targeting the
accumulation
of damaged
proteins okay so the more damaged
proteins you have
internally and externally the older
you're going to look and so i'm going to
talk about a lot of different parts of
this puzzle but let's start with
this term ages what is ages
stands for advanced
glycation
and products now what the heck is that
that is a combination
of a sugar molecule
with a protein molecule
when you take sugar and protein and you
heat them up you end up with these ages
okay so basically proteins
that are now damaged and unavailable and
they can create a lot of problems
throughout the body
but they can also make you look really
old now ages could also be a combination
of glucose and fat heated as well
so let me just kind of make this really
simple if you were to consume this thing
called
ice cream for example you're basically
heating
glucose lactose
sugar
with milk proteins
very high heats boy you're just
consuming a product that is just
loaded with these ages so ice cream
would be a perfect combination of fat
and sugar heated another one would be
barbecued ribs right you take these ribs
protein and you put all the sugar sauce
on it and you heat it and this is the
product when someone consumes a
barbecued ribs
they might notice about an hour later
that their their body is sluggish they
have a lot of sinus issues and so this
is why it's so important when you're
making barbecued ribs
use a sauce that doesn't have sugar use
spices like a dry rub that has no sugar
just spices and sea salt now what about
a soda yeah when you have all this sugar
and you have caramel coloring and you
heat this soda boy you're not just going
to get
the consumption of these ages but all
the sugar in your body
with the temperature of 98.6 is going to
combine with your own
blood proteins for example
and other proteins and create all this
damage protein binding combinations in
fact when you get your a1c tested you're
measuring the accumulation of excess
glucose in your bloodstream over a
period of three months so when you get
your a1c and it's high
it just tells us how much glycation is
going on in your red blood cells you
need to be in the lower fives not six
seven eight
i've had people had eleven all that
means is they're exposing their blood to
a lot of sugar creating glycation and
that protein and now is
damaged and it's going to clog a lot of
things up all right now let's take a
french fry which is a starch which is
basically kind of all these glucose
molecules stuck together
and then it also is deep fried in fat
okay so we have fat
plus the starch
deep fried equals a tremendous amount of
age so if you want to look really old
real fast
keep consuming fries then you have
potato chips right same deal starch with
some oil deep fried not good how about a
donut right you have this deep fried
donut boy you have
refined carbohydrate with
probably like
corn oil or soy oil or whatever type of
oil they use oh my gosh deadly
i remember going to
the kutztown fair in pennsylvania where
they had deep fried ice cream deep fried
potatoes and deep fried oreos deep fried
everything in fact you don't see a lot
of young people walking around on that
fair now what about a burger right a
hamburger well we have this meat with
ketchup
and then we have a bun
of course you want to add fries to that
and a coke wow you talk about ages on
steroids a perfect deadly combination to
look older really quick
and then you have pretty much every
combination of fast food
that you would find in a fast food
restaurant you have chinese food you
have mexican food these are all examples
of ages and these are things that make
you older and these are the things that
you need to avoid okay let's talk about
how to get rid of ages from your body
okay well the gesso happens to be a
condition called autophagy
which is like a an oven
that can cook and break down ages
damage proteins and
old proteins as in old skin cells
and it repurposes
these proteins so autophagy stands for
auto meaning self
feige means eating
so your body is eating its own proteins
in a way it's repurposing and recycling
old damaged proteins
and making new ones so autophagy is
really good for ages it's good for
old wrinkled skin
and it's an essential condition to make
you younger and the biggest way to get
into autophagy
is through fasting okay now for those of
you that are new to my channel i would
highly recommend starting with
intermittent fasting i put some links
down below but for those of you that
have been watching my channel that are
doing fasting already let's say you're
doing two meals a day i would recommend
going to one meal a day that's called
omad
now for those of you that are doing omad
i would recommend to do what's called
dry omad now what's dry omad i'll be
doing some videos on this topic but dry
fasting which is basically not consuming
any water as well as no food
creates
a
compounding effect
it's like three times as powerful
so if you're going to do dry omad you
would drink no water all day except
at night when you have that one meal but
a lot of people are doing dry fasting
for more than just one day they're doing
it for two days three days four days up
to seven days or a longer because you
can generate water from your fat cells
now i'm not going to get too much into
that in this video but it's very very
very very powerful but it's more
advanced and so i don't recommend it
unless you've done regular water fasting
for a period of time but if you want to
take the next level you want to start
doing dry fasting
with omega so i highly recommend
if you want youthful skin to get a
certain amount of sun okay but just make
sure you don't go to the burning level
there's certain types of light
frequencies or wavelengths like infrared
that
tend to buffer
the damaging effect of uv light and so
the benefit of infrared
wavelengths
can be extremely beneficial to looking
youthful because it's going to generate
a lot of
melatonin
and if you haven't seen my video
on that topic i put it down below but
melatonin is not all about sleep
it's about being an antioxidant and
getting rid of free radical damage
all of your cells can make melatonin and
so there's two types of melatonin one
for sleep one for antioxidants and one
way to generate that is through sunlight
you just want to make sure you don't
overdo it but regular exposure to sun
is extremely beneficial
to looking younger and that's one of the
problems in the winter when you can't
get sun you tend to look a bit older and
pasty and
you don't have that youthful glow now
let's talk about environment okay your
environment is just filled with
chemicals poisons drugs i mean it's just
really hard to avoid that thank goodness
we have
our liver that can
dismantle these poisons okay it can
dismantle heavy metals it can dismantle
pesticides and insecticides pollution
chemicals in your in the water chemicals
in the food and that's called phase one
phase two
detoxification okay and so your liver
has certain enzymes that can be boosted
with certain foods
to help get rid of poisons
so a really important part of looking
youthful is having a healthy liver if
your liver is serotic or filled with
cirrhosis scar tissue or it's filled
with fat or it's inflamed
you're going to look old so
anything you can do
to strengthen the liver is going to make
you look younger and there's a couple
things i'm going to just mention right
now
cruciferous vegetables okay
they have certain phytonutrients that
can boost
your natural enzymes to help phase one
phase two detoxification okay so that's
number one not to mention vegetables
giving you antioxidants directly to help
act as a scavenger or like a sponge to
clean up all this free radical damage
that's occurring due to inflammation or
chemicals or heavy metals etc so as you
add more
cruciferous vegetables like kale
broccoli brussels sprouts arugula i like
arugula in my salads you are going to
create a healthy liver and the thing
about the youthful look it has to be
created
continually okay a lot of times people
just neglect
this creation of health and then they
wonder someday where they what happened
to my body
but it has to be continually created
every single day
now a lot of these poisons and chemicals
and toxins that come through the liver
you need
bile to help eliminate these toxins so
bile is very very important in that
youthful look not just in the
elimination of toxic waste
but also in the extraction
of fat soluble vitamins which you need
desperately
to look youthful like vitamin a
e
d
and omega-3 fatty acids which is not a
vitamin but it's just a
essential nutrient which all these fat
soluble compounds that you need to make
the skin look
youthful is dependent on this bile so if
you don't have enough bile because of
various reasons let's say you have a
fatty liver
let's say you're on a low fat diet
because fat stimulates bile
or you have some type of you know let's
say you had gallstones and you removed
your gallbladder so a bile deficiency
will cause you to end up with a
deficiency of the fat cycle vitamins and
omega-3 fatty acids all the things that
you really need to look youthful so this
is why a combination
of enough bile and consuming enough fat
to get these fat cyber vitamins are
really necessary to have that youthful
look this is why people going on a low
fat diet end up looking older because
they don't have the benefits of the
vitamin a d
e and omega-3 fatty acids so let's just
touch on the type of fat that i'm
talking about i'm talking about like
fatty fish like salmon
amazing for omega-3 fatty acids which is
essential for the anti-inflammatories
and to counter all the omega-6 fatty
acids that are also in our diet like the
corn oil
canola soy oil the cottonseed oil it's
in just so many foods it's in foods that
you're going to find when you go out to
eat
and all that creates a lot of
inflammation and it just makes you look
older in fact it affects the eyes as in
age-related macular degeneration which
is
very very very common and just having
older looking skin but fatty fish is
very very important okay
the second thing is egg yolks you're
going to get a lot of good vitamin a
from egg yolks and you're also going to
get choline
in egg yolks that's great for a fatty
liver and to help you regulate
cholesterol there's lecithin in egg
yolks too which help regulate
cholesterol because people are as
concerned about the cholesterol and egg
yolks but it has the antidote to
that cholesterol as well
and also by the way
you need foods high in cholesterol to
build healthy
membranes in your cell to build healthy
sex hormones that make your skin look
youthful like testosterone and estrogen
you need all that good cholesterol to
make healthy looking skin this is why
people that are on cholesterol
medication like statins end up looking
really old and they end up having a lot
of side effects with the muscles and
inflammation
and
they can't make bile
you need cholesterol to make bile bile
is just so important and one thing you
start doing too is start taking purify
bile salts to help extract some of these
fat soluble nutrients from the cells if
you're deficient so egg yolks very very
important
butter
butter can give you a lot of vitamin a
don't be afraid to consume butter just
make sure it's grass-fed and then we get
to vitamin e now the best source of
vitamin e is sunflower seeds
but it's also in the leafy greens it's
in nuts
it's in vegetables okay so
vitamin e is very very important in skin
as well as internally now another good
oil would be cod liver well cod liver
oil has vitamin d
as well as vitamin a
as well as omega-3 fatty acids okay so
cod liver and cod liver oil very very
important as well as
beef liver too i personally can't eat it
because i don't like the taste but if
you like liver
liver and onions go for it organ meats
are loaded with these fat soluble
vitamins extra virgin olive oil very
very important avocados avocado oil
awesome for your skin so in other words
you don't want to go low fat
there's a diet which i don't recommend
by the way it's called ideal protein
now it's keto it's low carb
but it's also low fat
so it's not really
from my definition a healthy version of
the ketogenic diet and if you ever look
at someone who's done the ideal protein
diet
boy do they look old
there's their hair
their skin it looks all dried out
it doesn't look youthful so you might
lose weight
but
you don't look healthy now there's one
little interesting thing i want to tell
you about
vegetables okay
you might not think
that there's much fat in vegetables
but
a lot of the phytonutrients
like chlorophyll
like carotenoids and the list goes on
and on and on
are all fat soluble
so to extract these wonderful
antioxidants
as well as
amazing phytonutrients
you need
bile and you also need to eat them with
fat so
when you have a salad put the extra
virgin olive oil on it when you're
consuming
a cruciferous vegetable put some olive
oil on it consuming the greens with an
oil will help you extract these
wonderful phytonutrients which not only
are loaded with the antioxidants but
they also help that phase one phase two
detoxification we've talked about and by
the way phytonutrients also help
stimulate
autophagy okay on the topic of free
radical damage okay
in order to handle excess amount of free
radical damage
and oxidation which makes you look older
there's two types of antioxidants
there are endogenous antioxidants which
are antioxidants that your body makes
okay and then there's exogenous
antioxidants which you get from food
okay so if you need to consume a lot of
greens and vegetables to get those
antioxidants but your own body has
antioxidant networks which increase
when you exercise
which increase when you do fasting
so fasting
helps you with just about every aspect
of looking youthful and so every time
you do fasting you actually increase
antioxidants internally pretty cool now
i've already mentioned about the
combination of glucose and protein and
glucose and fat but just glucose in
general okay
consuming a high carb diet
is probably
the fastest way to look older because if
you ever take a look at a diabetic boy
they age so fast the sugar is like rust
and it oxidizes not just the inside of
your arteries and the eye and the nerves
and the brain and the kidney but your
skin it'll make your skin look really
old and every time you consume glucose
of any kind
you also at the same time block vitamin
c the chemistry of vitamin c is very
similar to glucose
and so you're blocking vitamin c
which is another powerful antioxidant
and you're also depleting other
antioxidants from your body when you
consume sugar and like vitamin b1 which
is also an antioxidant and you're
basically just
making your skin look really really old
very fast and of course if you smoke
you're really depleting these
antioxidants and vitamins especially
vitamin c that the requirement or demand
for antioxidants and vitamin c and other
vitamins go way up
if you're a smoker because you're
putting
all this pollution internally
so one way to age prematurely is just
just keep smoking so if your smoker do
whatever you can to you know kick the
habit but in the meantime if you're
making this transition
and you're coming off smoking or let's
say you're
coming off alcohol which is another way
to age very fast you want to take a lot
of antioxidants not from a pill but from
food you want to consume a lot of greens
to and do a lot of fasting and do all
the things that i'm talking about
to
counter
all this free radical damage that's
occurring in the body now another point
i want to bring up
is this thing called stress
stress puts your body into
two situations one it puts your body
into a glucose situation where
your your body is now
tapping into glucose's fuel it's turning
things into glucose so even though you
got off carbs
you're still consuming carbs if you have
a lot of stress so that's one thing and
then the other thing is that it's
creating a catabolic or a breakdown
effect of proteins
your skin
so one way to age is just to go through
a lot of stress
so you're going to have to actively
work hard at countering the amount of
stress
in our environment unfortunately you
can't escape it but you can do things to
counter it and slow it down you can
actively and aggressively do
continue regular exercise you can do a
lot of fasting both intermittent
and prolonged fasting you can do
physical work which is probably one of
the best ways to counter stress you can
work on improving your sleep okay and
one really great technique is to
control your breathing start breathing
through your nose especially when you're
sleeping and slow down your breathing i
i have a really good video on that if
you haven't seen that i will put a link
down below but controlled breathing can
pull you out of a panic attack and
really keep your stress under control
but stress is another factor that i need
to bring up because it's a really
important thing the other point i want
to bring up is
protein
you want to make sure the protein is
quality so organic grass-fed well caught
fatty fish
seafood is important for
quality proteins as well as trace
minerals which help the skin
then we have pasture-raised eggs
very very
important versus the commercial eggs
then you have wild caught animal
products and then we also get to the
amount of protein
a healthy ketogenic plan is a moderate
amount of protein it's not a high
protein diet what do you think happens
when you consume excessive amounts of
protein that you're not
converting into body proteins
well that protein is then used for fuel
and it's also creating a lot of waste in
your body so it's very important not to
overdo it on the protein if you want to
look youthful so
i'm not recommending going low protein
just a moderate amount a real simple
rule of thumb would be the amount of
protein
on the palm of your hand
times two if you're male
or just times one if you're female just
to keep it really really simple that
would be a moderate amount of protein
and then the last point i want to bring
up
is your microbiome
your microbes in your gut help make
fat fatty acids
called short chain fatty acids which are
really important in
controlling blood sugars
in making your insulin more sensitive in
getting rid of insulin resistance
they also make vitamins b vitamins they
also make factors that help your immune
system and decrease inflammation and on
top of that
they make secondary bile
so they help you make bile which is also
very very important in the extraction of
the fat type of vitamins
so having a really good microbiome is so
essential in that youthful look and one
of the best foods for establishing this
microbiome is fermented vegetables so
like the sauerkraut
probably the best food for your skin
but there are other types of things like
pickles and other fermented vegetables
that are very very important because
they give you the prebiotic and the
probiotic at the same time all right i
packed a lot of information in this
video i hope you took notes
watch it again
implement the stuff for that youthful
look but the next most important video
to watch
is on autophagy
so check it out i put it right here